We have breaking news just in to CNN.
The House
Homeland Security Committee
will formally begin impeachment
proceedings
against DHS Secretary Alejandro Mayorkas.
CNN's Lauren Fox joins us
now from Washington, D.C..
And Laura, what details do you have?
Yeah, we are learning more information
that in this new year,
the House Republicans
are planning to forge ahead
with an impeachment
against Alejandro Mayorkas,
the secretary of homeland Security.
Obviously, this comes
at a really complicated
political moment for House Republicans
and for the Congress at large.
That is because right now
there is bipartisan efforts
in the United States
Senate to try to reach
some kind of framework agreement
that could actually improve
border security along the U.S.
southern border.
Those talks have been hard fought.
They've been going on for weeks.
And while they don't
have an agreement yet,
they are trying to reach one
in order to pass this larger
supplemental package,
which would include
funding for Ukraine
and Israel as well as money for the U.S.
southern border.
But this dynamic
now that the House Republicans
are planning
to move forward with this impeachment
proceedings against New York is shows
you just how hard it is going to be,
even if the Senate can reach a deal
to get that deal
through the House of Representatives.
So right now, there's a
this is a complicating dynamic
as the Senate
is continuing those efforts.
And they're in Washington
working today
to try to find
an agreement
on that bipartisan border
security proposal.
All right, Lauren, thanks so much.
And joining us now is Homeland
Security Secretary Alejandro Mayorkas.
Mr. Secretary, appreciate your time.
This was not planned.
This way,
but since
the House Republicans
have telegraphed for a while
that they wanted to move
in this direction or plan to now
appear to be doing so,
I think what my colleague
Laura was just talking about
is the critical point here.
You are so deeply engaged
in the border negotiations
that are going on in the Senate.
Does this undercut
any possibility
of getting a deal under the House floor?
Oh, I certainly hope not.
Phil, and thanks very much
for having me this morning.
You know, yesterday
I joined the bipartisan group of senators
who are negotiating
a solution to a much
plagued
broken immigration system.
I was very privileged
to participate in that before I did so.
I was hard at work in the office
with my colleagues
addressing the situation at the border
and addressing the many other challenges
that the Department
of Homeland Security confronts.
And after I participated
in those negotiations
in providing technical
and operational advice
to the bipartisan group of Senators,
I returned to the office
to perform
the work of the Department
of Homeland Security.
We have a broken immigration system.
That is the one single fact about which
everyone agrees,
and our administration
is focused on solutions.
And we're really pleased to join
a bipartisan group of senators
who are similarly focused on solutions.
Is there.
And I think one of the questions
that I've had over the course
the last two weeks,
and I don't think I'm alone in this, is
even if you guys reach a deal
or if the senators reach a deal
and you've obviously been
providing the technical assistance
at length over the course
of the last couple of weeks,
is there any commitment
that House
Republicans will move
forward on an agreement
if they get 60 senators,
especially when
not only is there impeachment,
but the speaker
and I think dozens of his colleagues
will be at the border
today talking about this issue.
Well,
when they're at the border,
they're going to see the magnitude
of the problem
and why we have said now
for about three decades
that our broken
immigration system is in desperate
need of legislative reform.
So we are focused on solutions,
and we hope that they will return
to Washington
and focus on the solutions as well.
Are you communicating with House
Republican leadership,
with the speaker's office right now?
Right now,
I am focused on providing the technical
and operational advice
that is
that the bipartisan group of senators
have asked me to provide
and I feel very privileged to do so.
You're not only
are we doing that to advance
the negotiations,
we're very focused on them.
But we've also submitted
this administration
has submitted
a package to Congress
for additional resources
to plus up the number of Border
Patrol agents
to plus up the number of asylum officers,
immigration judges to infuse
our system with much needed resources.
You know, to that point,
we talk a lot about what happens
if the Ukraine aid runs out.
Are you at risk?
Is DHS at risk
without this national security
supplemental package
of running out of funding?
And what happens in that case,
given how stretched
the border
and the government
is at the border right now?
We will not have the resources
to perform
our jobs as fully and completely
as we could do so.
And that would be
a very sad state of affairs.
When do you have a date
on those additional resources?
We need them now.
And that is why the president
submitted a supplemental funding package
quite some time ago.
We need additional personnel
to advance our security at the border.
We need to acknowledge
to advance our fight against fentanyl.
We need additional asylum officers
to really accelerate
the asylum adjudication process
so people are not waiting
six years
before they receive their results,
which is, in effect, a key factor.
The fact that people can stay here
for six years
before their asylum cases adjudicated.
Is a powerful example
of how broken
our immigration system is
and has been for so long.
We have a backlog of cases
of about 3 million
in immigration court proceedings
that has been building year
over year over year for decades.
Now,
when it comes,
I want to get to the specifics
of what you're talking
with the border crisis
and the issues
you guys have been dealing with
or stretched to try and deal with.
But what
I am interested,
have you closed out any issues
in the bipartisan negotiations,
the discussions that have been ongoing?
And do you feel like the issues
that we've been talking about
over the course
of the last couple of months
raising credible fear
standard for asylum seekers
expelling migrants at the border?
Would that have a tangible reduction
in border crossings?
So, Phil, I'm not going to
get into the particulars
of the negotiations.
I will say this,
that the negotiations have made
the negotiators have made
substantial progress.
They are focused on solutions
and they are focused on solutions
that will that will deliver results.
And improve a broken system,
including and very importantly,
a broken asylum system.
When we talk about numbers,
ABC News is reporting
there are over 300,000
border encounters in December.
CNN has reported
or 225,000 were apprehensions
from illegal crossings.
These are record numbers.
This has been a continuous
trend line right now.
Is there anything on the executive
authority side
that you haven't done yet
that you think you can
that can stem this?
We are focused
on the fundamental solution
to a long, existing problem.
And that fundamental solution
is legislation.
We have taken actions already
to build lawful pathways
to deliver consequences
and do what we can.
We've promulgated regulations
to do what we can
within the confines of the law.
But fundamentally,
the law is the laws
themselves must change.
And this is something
about which everyone, one agrees,
and that is quite rare
when one is speaking about immigration.
Yeah, it's not the only thing
and immigration
that anybody seems to agree
with on some level.
Sir, can I ask you
just on a personal level,
you've been in this job
since the start of the administration.
I think you take heat on a lot of issues.
You have a massive agency
that draws heat on
just about everything that you guys do.
The idea
of of impeachment proceedings starting.
Does that affect you at all in a personal
I know you work
and you continue to do the work,
but what do you think when you see that,
you know, feel?
I come to the office every morning and
I am surrounded by incredible,
talented and dedicated people
and it is extraordinarily motivating
to see the work
they do
to witness firsthand their selflessness,
their talent, their tireless dedication.
Many sacrifice a tremendous amount.
That's what I think about.
And I'm incredibly proud
to work alongside them
and to support them
in advancing the mission
of the Department of Homeland Security
on behalf of the American people
under President Biden's leadership.
That's what I think about every day.
And I'm incredibly proud
of coming to work every day and leaving
the office as late as it might be.
Having
done the work with
such extraordinary people.
Last one before I let you go.
You've been engaged
in bilateral discussions
with your counterparts in Mexico.
Pretty critical discussions
with Mexican officials are going to come
to the United States soon.
Have you seen a tangible effect
of what you guys
have discussed up to this point,
what you've
started to implement up to this point?
So, Phil, we we've started to see
some results.
These are not results that occur.
The the flick of a switch.
I also have an engagement
with my counterpart from Panama later
this week.
The issue of migration is a regional one.
The challenge is a regional one
and requires regional solutions,
which is why Secretary Blinken,
Homeland Security
Adviser SHERWOOD-RANDALL
and I
and our entire delegation
was down in Mexico last week.
And why I will be traveling there again
and will be traveling in other parts
of the hemisphere
to address
a regional solution
to what is a regional challenge.
At the same time,
with respect to the interest
of the United States
and our southern border,
most particularly,
it is Congress that must act.
And I am hopeful
that the bipartisan group of senators
will achieve a legislative solution,
that the entire Congress will pass
and we will
we will see reform
that has long been needed.
Secretary Alejandro Mayorkas,
we appreciate your time, sir. Thank you.